i don't have more things to do
the wash clothes fix a house
i have a lot of work
i have to do it
these days norma flores's worries seem
to keep piling up
she's been out of work since march
[Music]
we lose everything now is six kids
my daughter and my son and me
and the house is too small but we don't
have choices
we have to stay here because we don't
have money
flores left mexico 30 years ago full of
dreams for her life
in the u.s
she worked as a server at a casino just
outside las vegas for two decades
when the coronavirus pandemic took hold
she was let go
now flora struggles to feed her six
grandchildren every day
each trip to the grocery store requires
strategic planning
this time it's just water and snacks for
the kids
she's strapped for cash
but she still decides to donate a dollar
to a nearby food bank
flores is one of many immigrants who
have disproportionately suffered job
loss due to the pandemic
in and around las vegas immigrant
workers make up most of the hospitality
industry
through working class jobs in hotels
casinos and restaurants
but visitors to vegas plummeted by more
than 90 percent
after the initial lockdown and the
state's unemployment skyrocketed to 28
per
cent
the culinary workers union represents 60
000 people in and around las vegas
most of them like flores are immigrants
more than
half of them are currently out of work a
lot of people who come to las vegas
you're coming to look for a you know
better life
we have like less than 25 000 people
back to work
for flores the situation is hardest for
her grandchildren
come away medicine grandma
possibly next week because i have to pay
that rent
next week and it's hard because they're
little
nori nasser the associated press las
vegas